la force des artistes c'est l'émotion
celle des scientifiques la raison réunir
ces deux forces peut réduire le fossé
entre les chercheurs qui étudient la
maladie de parkinson et ceux qui en
souffrent un projet inédit
il y à 7 ans l'avis d'anne cahuzac a été
chamboulé par un diagnostic de paul
qu'il se
promène avec un petit nuage noir qui
toutes les fonctions physiques le
tremblement la difficulté de marché la
lenteur la la raideur
des difficultés de concentration la
difficulté de mémoire
à nous chacun mèche de son côté étudie
comment se développent la maladie de
parkinson chez les souris a working je
travaille sur un style de parkinson
causée par une mutation
j'étudie s'il ya des changements précoce
dans le cerveau des souris
les deux femmes ont un objectif commun
venir à bout de la maladie de parkinson
pourtant elles vivent dans des mondes à
part qui se croise rarement j'ai trouvé
que des fois on est traité beaucoup
comme des choses puis comme ce qu'ils
peuvent déplacer à l'art à leur guise
c'est un peu énervant
la majorité de mon travail et sur des
animaux et des tissus cheshire symbole
c'est très loin de l'aspect clinique
de son côté la chercheuse en
neurosciences nayla kullman a constaté
durant ses études que cette distance
nuisait à l'avancement de la recherche
j'ai fait mon doctorat sur la maladie de
parkinson donc dire oh mon doctorat
j'avais très peu de contacts avec les
personnes vivant avec la maladie et je
sentais que je n'étais pas seul
là-dedans qui a beaucoup de chercheurs
au moins au niveau vraiment
neurobiologiques qui n'ont pas beaucoup
de contacts avec la communauté de
parkinson et que ça empêche l'échangé
des connaissances mais ça empêche aussi
qu'on a des retours de la communauté
qu'on apprend ceux qui sont les
priorités pour les personnes vivant avec
la maladie
nayla a donc choisi de consacrer sa
recherche postdoctorale à combler ce
fossé
pour y parvenir elle a choisi un moyen
inhabituel pour des scientifiques
les arts de la scène
[Musique]
dans le cadre de son projet intitulé
peace of mind elle a rassemblé des
chercheurs dans le domaine du parkinson
et de la démence des patients ainsi que
des musiciens des danseurs et des
artistes de cirque
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de faire un
échange de connaissances scientifiques
mais aussi de l'expérience vécue et de
travailler ensemble intégré ça donc de
spectacle
l'hypothèse de naïla est la suivante les
arts permettrait aux patients de
communiquer plus en profondeur et avec
plus de sensibilité leur vécu aux
chercheurs
selon elle des chercheurs plus
empathique envers ceux qui souffrent de
la maladie seraient de meilleurs
chercheurs
je trouve que c'est important d'avoir
l'empathie dans la recharge parce que ça
nous ramène au niveau humain et ça nous
donne la perspective de même si on ne
peut pas aider quelqu'un deux jours d'un
jour un autre ça vaut la peine de faire
cette recherche
sa collègue anusha n'a pas hésité à se
joindre au projet en plus d'être
chercheuse elle est aussi une pianiste
accomplie i want the opportunity act je
voulais avoir l'occasion de parler aux
gens qui souffrent de cette maladie que
j'étudie depuis trois ans
en russie en france ce qui est important
pour eux et ce qui ne l'est pas leur
quotidien de voir ce qu'il va
l'apprendre ne ma recherche et qu'est ce
que je peux leur apporter
dans le cadre de ce projet anne et
anusha ont été jumelés à la
clarinettiste louise kembo
et à la danseuse de claquettes
violoniste et docteur en neurosciences
claire honda j'avais envie de mieux
comprendre un peu l'expérience des gens
qui vivent avec la démence et le
parkinson puis en même temps c'est
vraiment cool de réunir tous ces
artistes différents avec des talents
vraiment varié puis de voir ce qu'on
peut créer ensemble c'est vraiment un
paquetage donc c'est pas seulement moi
qui fais de la musique pour eux c'est
les gens qui donnent quelque chose à moi
je peux de transférer de manière et leur
donner un biberon
les quatre femmes ont rapidement trouvé
le concept derrière leur collaboration
raconté comment les journées dalles sont
dictées par les symptômes de sa maladie
et par les médicaments qu'elle doit
prendre plusieurs fois par jour la
première session nous a dit que le temps
pour elle c'est pas mesuré par les
minutes mais les hommes mais pas le
médicament
à chaque jour fait vraiment des
montagnes russes
j'ai appris ce que ça veut dire un jour
à la fois que tu es quand il semblerait
que pour une raison pour une autre
médicament ne prend pas et tous les
impôts y reviennent de façon extrêmement
marqué moi je le ressens énormément à
l'intérieur de ma tête les deux mon
corps
non
anouch à claire et louise traduisent
chacune à leur façon la fluctuation des
symptômes du parkinson
le tout guidé par leur chef d'orchestre
anne
ont commencé avec l'idée que s'ils
étaient vraiment très haut avec les
mains et s'étaient vite et plus aigus
ébats avec les mains c'était plus lent
ou même pas dans l'écrin que cette appli
mobile est très grave
c'est beau la clarinette et feutrée mais
c'est tellement précis dans les toutes
les petits détails le contrôle et
d'égratignures petite profondeur des
noirs ferme tout était là
à nous c'est est toujours en recherche
de d'harmonie andreck à la feuille de me
calmer qui demeure non non c'est beau
tout mon corps et puis c'est bien si on
vote vont reprendre une kim nhan
pour claro début était tout comme direct
comme mary poppins avec ses pingouins
le rythme est toujours due forme ce que
faisait
le tas quoi s'est mis à faire
un pis si près dix ans comme
complètement
il ya eu beaucoup de moments comme ça où
machine danser ensemble et ont seulement
senti qu au hac on a créé quelque chose
de spécial puis que j'avais commencé à
comprendre un peu son expérience pour de
vrai
bien qu'elles proviennent d'univers
différents
les participantes sont parvenus à se
comprendre avec le langage universel
dollars
socialement c'est chiant parce que elle
disait que ses mots son expérience puis
nous l'avez entendu gwynn fils je pense
que je me sentirai un peu vide si je
n'avais plus de lien avec les patients
de cette façon elles ne soient égales
j'ai l'impression que j'ai appris qu'il
y avait un humain autour des faits d'une
carrière
[Musique]
je cherche maintenant des occasions
d'intégrer l'aspect humain ma recherche
shopping et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je fais ce
projet beaucoup plus forte
c'est une grande source de motivation
c'est
la famille ne me vois pas comme une
personne manana maladie parkinson après
des mois de création les participants du
projet peace of mind sont enfin prêts à
présenter leurs oeuvres au grand public
et moi ce crime ce qui me regarde pas
comme quelqu'un de malade nayla souhaite
maintenant que son projet inspire
d'autres initiatives du genre j'aimerais
que l'impact principal des ans et
l'empathie que les chercheurs qui voient
ce spectacle sorte en pensant à oui on
n'a jamais vraiment pensé à ça on
devrait avoir plus de dialogue avec la
communauté et on devrait impliquer les
personnes vivant avec la maladie plus
dans notre recherche juste avoir cette
connaissance ou d'avoir ce contact sans
tête ça peut aider à développer des
meilleurs traitements qui sont aussi
plus humain est non seulement efficace
[Musique]